like so much last night Hannah Browns
windmill lover is revealed and we
finally see that crazy convo with Luke P
you don't mind me you don't get to
decide what I care and he did I was like
oh my god who are you
fans got what they've been waiting for
on Monday night's episode of The
Bachelorette as Hannah brown took three
of her four remaining men to fantasy
suites and crate Greece including the
man she slept with in a windmill which
was drumroll Peter I'm happy for instant
in the world and this definitely I feel
like can be one of the best nights of my
life
sweet sweet after Peters date Hannah got
hot and heavy with fan favorite Tyler
but it didn't get to windmill level as
Hannah voiced her concerns with Tyler
about their intense physical chemistry I
have to kind of reset myself sometimes
and think okay like that's great you
know that that's there but like it has
to be war
I like I don't want to go into fantasy
suite and have sex because I don't feel
like that's what our relationship needs
Tyler handled it like a true gentleman
yeah I just want to be with you and had
that time with you you have to really
love and respect and honor each other's
boundaries then there was Jed the pair
also decided to forgo their individual
rooms for the fantasy suite
but not before Jed voiced his now
seemingly ill-intentioned concerns about
Luke P let's remember he allegedly had a
girlfriend right before joining the show
I was thinking why I just don't fully
understand how you can be as amazing as
you are and even consider someone like
Kevin Luke's date started off great with
a helicopter ride over to Santorini but
things that quickly crumbled between the
pair when Luke questioned Hanna about
her sexual relationships with the other
men I don't believe that's something
that you should be doing and I just want
to make sure you're not going to be you
know sexually intimate with you know the
other relationships here
the enemy is refusing me to get into
that vehicle right now because my if you
really I can probably get you to go in
that limo it from what you said I'm like
he's so mad
so like I have had sex
yeah
you know Jesus still loves me
from obviously how you feel me you know
windmill probably probably literally
shortly after the episode aired Luke
took to Instagram to clarify the
intention behind his words writing in
part it hurt my heart that Hannah felt I
was shaming her our conversations and
our beliefs led me to believe we were on
the same page about sex for me it was
never about getting a rose it was always
about finding a wife hashtag faithful
over famous et caught up with Hannah at
the men tell all
taping last week where she opened up
about that uncomfortable conversation
that rocked bachelor nation we found out
that the windmill is Peter did Peter get
a heads up that you had to reveal the
two times in the windmill I thought what
I didn't have the heads up in my brain
yeah that that was gonna come out but
like did he know before the episode
aired I unclear okay I cannot say you
ended up getting backed into a corner
and having to reveal your sex life how
frustrating was that for you it was
really frustrating for me I will be very
honest when asked anything but I felt
like that question was really pointed
because it was contingent on whether he
was going to stay or not or really
whether I was worthy of him his love
because before that he had said he loved
me he wanted to marry me but he needed
to know my intimacy with the other guys
for him
no if I was worth it or not
[Applause]
[Music]